did you provide information to mr
zarif on israeli operations against
iranian-backed
terrorists during or following your
tenure as secretary of state
on no occasion never never so mr zarif
is a liar
mr zarif may be confused or incorrect
okay first off you shouldn't be wearing
a mask everybody's been vaccinated no
one's near you
you see just a big misunderstanding
former secretary of state john kerry
said
once again lying about his dealings with
iran's foreign minister perhaps
the former secretary of state testifying
today that he did not leak israeli
secret
operations to syria to iran's top
diploma diplomat meanwhile kerry was
evasive about his meetings with zarif
but if we learned anything from this
hearing is that he has trouble
remembering stuff for example
did you meet with iranian foreign
minister zarif in munich
during the munich security conference in
february 2019.
i i don't know if i met with him between
i don't have a recollection of 2019.
do you maybe you don't remember i know i
met with him
i know i met with him in 2018
and i met with him
i met with him i think twice in 2018 and
twice in 2017. i recall meeting him i
just can't remember exactly which year
yeah i know how that gets remember he
does remember having a beer with rush
conspiracy
theory adam schiff remember adam schiff
do you recall having an extended
conversation with the house intelligence
committee chairman adam schiff
at the munich security conference
uh i think we had a i think
we had a beer well he was spotted in the
hole without beer
uh you know a guy that would rather have
a beer right now but he has pledged to
talk to me first is florida senator
marco rubio
senator is it possible to remember what
happened in 2018 and not in 2019
well i think it's impossible to say you
don't remember if you met with a foreign
minister of another country and i think
the answer to that is that well you
could say look i'm not sure if it was in
munich i'm not sure if it was
in 2018 but i know i met with them on
several occasions those meetings
happened and i can't tell you they
weren't talking about the yankees
or the state of play in the national
football league i mean there's only one
thing that two have in common
and the one thing they have in common is
the iran deal and if i were to bet
what he was saying in those meetings it
was listen this is don't hold on this
guy's not gonna be president two and a
half or three years
a new administration will come in and
set these things right
i think that's what what those meetings
are about i can't prove it i don't think
anyone can but you know
that what else would they be talking
about it's the only thing they have in
common
for the first time in four years we have
wild bombings and missile strikes on
both sides
and with between israel and the
palestinians is this a coincidence
well look i think there's a lot of
factors that played into it but
ultimately what you have here
is a situation where hamas wants to
prove they're stronger than the
palestinian authority
and they've launched i think over a
thousand rockets it's the most it's the
biggest barrage we've ever seen from
them
and they're indiscriminate firing right
i mean they're just firing into tel aviv
firing at the airport
firing into jerusalem and people talk
about the israeli response you know the
israeli response
and in most cases is they actually do
that roof knocking right where they drop
non-explosives to warn people they even
call people they actually canceled
schools
in gaza so that kids wouldn't be in
these buildings but the fundamental
problem that's happening over there is
that islamic jihad and hamas
they have no problem putting the
operation sites the missile sites
right next to a nursery or a hospital or
a residential building i mean
and so at the end of the day i don't
care what happened on the ground in
jerusalem the response cannot be
a thousand rockets fired into civilian
areas senator why don't you take a look
at a tweet by neil and omar and it just
shows you
president biden might have one opinion
but a lot of people in his
in his caucus have a different opinion
she tweeted out this israeli airstrikes
killing civilians in gaza is an act of
terrorism palestinians deserve
protection
unlike israel missile defense programs
such as iron dome don't exist to protect
them
it's unconscionable to not condemn these
acts on the week
of uh ayad uh i guess that's the way you
say it
is she right she's she's out of her mind
when for when she put that there number
one is the
iron dome wouldn't need to exist if it
wasn't for hamas and hezbollah the
reason it exists is because these
these elements terrorists have rockets
and they use it to try to kill israelis
that's the reason why it exists
number two is the only response that
you've seen from israel is in response
to these attacks
and they live in a very tough
neighborhood and they made abundantly
clear if you hit us we're going to hit
you back five times harder
and enemas knows that this is a plan
okay
they do this knowing there's going to be
a response knowing that
innocents are going to be killed and
civilians that are going to be killed
they know it's going to happen
and they deliberately want it to happen
so they can get tweets like that and
people around the world
to take up their cause these are an
organization that pays bonuses which by
the way was just restored
you know giving back money to the
palestinian authority and and through
them as well
uh hamas if you are a martyr as they
call it if you
kill yourself by trying to go after the
israelis they pay your family
a stipend for the rest of their lives
they pay them a martyr's benefit if you
go to jail for trying to kill or killing
an israeli when you get out they promise
you a job they promise you a pension
and they take care of your family while
you're in there they create financial
incentive for these attacks
both the palestinian authority and hamas
those are the terrorists
with no strings attached we restored
their money that's what we're referring
to that stopped over the last four years
because of their terrorist acts and
irresponsibility generally
in both the west bank as well as gaza
let's go back to john kerry for a second
you know he is the climate czar
and he wants uh the number one polluter
uh china
to start stepping to the table they're
not big shocker
but he also admitted this about who
makes solar panels
and the ones that we might be buying
listen
how can you assure us or ensure that
that
that this uh quest that we're on
that that slave labor coming out of
china
where genocide is taking place as we
speak are never a part of the climate
solution
in the united states uh it is a problem
the zhanjiang province not only produces
some of the solar panels
that we believe are being in some cases
produced in forced labor
by uyghurs he calls it a problem it's a
problem no it's not a problem it's a
catastrophe
it's a humanitarian catastrophe it's an
outrage it's genocide
they are being produced and not just
that but all kinds of apparel we have
american corporations that are profiting
from this as well from the cheap and
free labor
provided through slave labor of uyghur
muslims in the xinjiang region of
china it's absolutely a fact that it's
happening and it isn't outrage
if we know that how should americans
feel about buying
for example two companies h m and nike
who have spoken up about this and got
slapped down by the chinese government
what should we know about companies like
that getting their products made from
people who are basically in the middle
of genocide
well we shouldn't have products like
that coming into the united states and
into our market it's as simple as that i
actually have a bill that helps achieve
that we shouldn't have it
it's a simple straightforward i don't
care who the company is
move your factory somewhere else but no
american corporation or any corporation
for that matter should be profiting
off of the slave labor of anyone
including the slave labor of uyghur
muslims
i think we learn we got to bring our
manufacturing back we'll pay a little
bit more in order to do it and i just
hope the pressure
that we put on these companies to be
green could be the same pressure we put
on these companies to come back home
this way we know who's making the stuff
uh senator marco rubio thanks so much
hey
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now